potentially clean your house in the
future with this robot flies concept and
if you need a caffeine boost just let it
absorb through your skin with sprayable
energy Vsauce Kevin here this is mine
[Music]
two baby rabbits were successfully born
glowing fluorescent green researchers at
the University of Hawaii injected a
naturally glowing jellyfish protein into
embryos in a pregnant rabbit and two of
the babies born ended up carrying the
gene the point is to be able to
eventually make rabbits that produce
medicine in their milk and the green
glow allows researchers to see which
animals have gotten the specific gene
researchers at the University of Tokyo
are working on creating electronic skin
they've been developing flexible
electronic mesh to wrap around robot
hands for over a decade and are now
bringing it to humans the east' skin can
bend stretch and twist and is ten times
thinner than kitchen plastic wrap right
now it can be used to monitor vital
signs but eventually could be used to
make humans hyper aware or communicate
simply with our skin the University of
Washington meanwhile have achieved a
breakthrough in direct brain to brain
communication a professor linked to
another professor used his thoughts to
control the other's actions making the
linked professor involuntarily move his
hand and press a spacebar to play a
computer game and while basic hand
movements are technically a pretty
simple brain signal it does open the
door for exploring the possibilities of
sending more advanced brain signals to
each other
researchers at university of molecular
biotechnology in Vienna Austria have
grown a 3d tiny human brain the mini
three-dimensional brain models were
grown using stem cells and include parts
of the cortex hippocampus and retinas
and right now they're using these to
study early fetal brain development but
hope to eventually grow larger brains to
provide insights into conditions such as
schizophrenia and autism it turns out
seahorses have squishable armor to help
protect them from being crushed by
predators and researchers at the
University of California San Diego are
building a robotic arm from three
printed plates mimicking this
compressible design so yeah the ug is a
new shower head that makes you aware of
how long you've been in the shower
so far they've noticed a 12% decrease in
shower time and say that the $50 shower
head will pay for itself within seven
months
it works by turning from green to red
after seven minutes and the hope is that
people are out of the shower by minute
eight the sesame ring looks to simplify
paying for public transportation by
wearing your pass on your finger the
rings are 3d printed and come in a
variety of colors and while it's
designed to work in Boston right now
they're looking to bring this worldwide
yeah I'll be right there just let me
fold up my Korean armadillo car pocket
spacecraft is giving you the ability to
send yourself into outer space in a way
you can upload a picture and a
personalized message to your spacecraft
that's smaller than a CD and as thin as
a piece of paper which will then be
launched along with thousands of others
into space check out the website for
more architect Shigeru Ban made a six
million dollar Cathedral out of
cardboard tubes and even though it's
made out of cardboard it's more
structurally sound in the previous
Cathedral that was lost in an earthquake
the structure is called the transitional
Cathedral and is also apparently
fireproof and waterproof bumpy photo
will turn standard 2d photos into 3d
sculptures the photos can be made as
small as one inch or as large as 15
inches and all you have to do is upload
a picture of your choice to the website
wait for the conversion and production
and then have it sent to your doorstep
finally youtuber vac on use the oculus
rift virtual reality system a harness to
hang 15 feet off the ground and
skydiving software to create a virtual
skydiving demo
going right in has a gun get it Babu the
hall Oh baby I'm gonna leave you with
robots laying out slot car track
seriously this is awesome and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]